foreign
Jacksonville Florida hi Joe how are you
hey guys how are you better than we
deserve what's up
well I really need your advice but I
told my wife I did not want to call and
get the public Dave Ramsey Smackdown
because I know I've been stupid but I am
a step six
repeat offender because I'm a real
estate addict and every time we do our
quiet debt-free screen I managed to go
out and do stupid again and buy another
real rental real estate property
but the question I have is we have a
mortgage I want to eliminate on step six
again
and how much or how do we best wisely
calculate our emergency fund how deep
can I go we have the ability to pay it
all
but the emergency fund for our personal
income
is one question but then I guess the
real question is for the rental
portfolio how much of a capital reserve
do we need
yeah good for you well your personal is
three to six months of expenses
um on a business and that's what a
rental portfolio is it's a business you
would have what we call retained
earnings
and um you know retained earnings would
go for emergencies
uh repairs like for instance the heating
and air goes out or something like that
and what also uh you would also build
and and calculate your retained earnings
if you're doing it well for replacement
of large items like say you've got a
roof uh that's going to need to be
replaced in five years then you want to
be setting aside a fifth of that roof
each year so that it doesn't sneak up on
you you know and so you we've got a you
know we've got a apartment complex that
the parking lot is going to have to be
redone
um and you know that's a hundred
thousand dollar expense or whatever it
is right and uh we got three years to do
that though so we're going to put 33 000
aside for three years you know that kind
of a thing so you would systematically
build into your major repairs to keep
you from having uh
you know something quote unquote sneak
up on you that shouldn't really sneak up
on you and then the second thing you
would hold is just retained earnings for
the totally unexpected uh but how many
houses have you gotten now
we have uh 19 and
um about 20
23 different units within that yeah have
you got a pre how long you been doing
this
about 20 years you know I had a career
you probably got a pretty good set of
books that you you could probably look
back and say
you know here you know average per house
or average per ten houses or something
uh here's what my unexpected repairs are
water heaters and heat and air
um you know whatever else and you know
you've got replacement carpet
replacement paint replacement on
turnover that's standard tenant stuff
right
um not every time you turn them over but
occasion every every two or three times
you turn them over you're gonna have to
go through and hit that inside pretty
hard we do anyway uh and so on you're
probably used to doing all that I would
say your P L's if you look back through
them would inform
your retained earnings pretty accurately
uh and in combination with that I would
look forward and say what are known
Replacements and repairs that are large
that I've got coming in the next five to
ten years three to ten years and you
know or whatever and let's add that in
there too and somewhere in there is
going to give you a real Common Sense
number on the retained earnings
okay
consistent experience has been about 50
percent of the gross revenue goes to
manage and retain the business and then
we cash flow about 50 yeah that sounds
that doesn't sound unusual
um so if we if we cancel it depend on
the age of the properties that that you
know if it's a newer property it
shouldn't be that high but um you know
if these are 10 year old 15 year old
properties you probably are seeing that
because you're heating an air starter
should we um keep retaining a full
Year's worth of expenses in reserve then
no it's like six six months
okay you know all right because you've
not you've not had any cash flow you're
managing your cash already
um you know you're joking around about
you continue to go back into debt that's
a different issue but you're already
managing your cash you've been doing
this too long you got too many
properties if you were doing it poorly
it would already knocked you off the
saddle
yeah I did I want to knock out this last
mortgage I just didn't know how
aggressive I could be with my reserves
well I mean obviously it's kind of like
your personal if you take it down to a
thousand dollars and you pay off your
house heat and air will go out the next
day you know so you don't you don't want
to invite Murphy to the party
so let's just you know let's give it a
little little wiggle room here and not
go too too aggressive but also you don't
need a year and a half's worth of cash
sitting there while you got a mortgage
on you that you can reach over and knock
out with with a few months of that
reserve and but it's like any other
business you can plan out your known
you you get a rhythm of the emergencies
once you've got enough volume like
you've got if you had two houses it's
harder to do but when you got 20 and 23
units you can you can start to get some
averages and you've been doing it a
while and you'll get you'll get pretty
accurate on it
so real estate for me is it's a
fascinating topic I feel like even right
now in our world not just with the
housing prices being up but this is more
I mean I feel like more than ever
hearing people trying to get in to real
estate investing and it being part of
their world I mean it's it feels like
it's everywhere and obviously uh you
know Joe's been doing this for a long
time but do you feel like there's been a
research like a surge of that too versus
10 years ago yeah there was a really
last spring we talked about it a lot
there was a real move and you could feel
it in social media and you could feel it
with Gen Z there was this move of get
rich quick real estate pop back up which
kind of was like making real estate cool
again yeah so talk talk you know talk to
everyone about the wisest way to do it
because we teach cash but a lot of
people are like that seems that's
impossible there's no way I could get in
not important just gotta have the cash
it's not impossible at all you got to
wait till you have the cash and it's uh
so what it must do is buy that first
property if you're buying houses for
example and let's say you're gonna buy
200 000 rental property which is not
that unusual in a lot of cities some of
your cities that that's not possible but
just call it that and you go okay I'm
Gonna Save 40 Grand a year for five
years it takes a little while yeah but
the first one when you get the first one
then you've got the cash flow off of
that and you got no payments
and so you could throw that at this
savings for the next one and by the time
you've got three or four uh pretty
quickly you can buy a house a year off
of the income from the houses you know
uh that kind of a thing so it snowballs
in a good way that way the snowball
rolls over and over and that's how we
did it right we first bought houses
um and then 2008 hit and I was sitting
on a bunch of cash
and we got into a bunch of commercial at
pennies at 15 cents on the dollar it was
ridiculous so
but the weird thing is if you'll be
patient get yourself in a cash position
you'll find deals and you'll find the
market slows and there's a moment in
time where you can jump in I've never
I've been in real estate business 30
plus years in one way or another and
I've never seen anything as good as that
2000 how you was it was wonderful for
buying for buying yeah because we were
buying it Pennies on the dollar and I
don't know that I'll ever see it again
but I made a lot of money that year two
years really